,
come on.
Lord,
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
forch.
[Silence]
Muslim.
for
[Silence]
Wasam.
for
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Waaala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in describing his truly
believing servants,
those from amongst his
servants that will inherit the paradise.
And not just any part of the paradise
but they will inherit the highest levels
of paradise.
El ferdos
he tells us subhanahu wa ta'ala
describing them or we should say
describing one of their most critical
components and hallmarks.
He says subhanahu waala
and those who are ever dutiful
in giving their zaka the zakiah of their
wealth.
He elaborates on this elsewhere
in which he describes his believing
servants.
He describes elus.
He describes those
whom their hearts have been chosen and
prepared by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to be filled with his revelation
and his names and attributes
and to be filled with knowledge of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He says in their description
and those
whom in their wealth
is a known and set
a known and set right that belongs to
those who ask
and that belongs to those who
are in desperate need.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, notice the
wording here. He says,
notice the wording that he uses.
He says, "And those whom in their wealth
exists a right,
a portion of their wealth, that is a
right that belongs
to those who are
less privileged
to those who are impoverished and those
who are needy
and are asking.
This
a known set right.
This is what we know as zak.
It is a known and set right that is
contained within the wealthy
individual's
property and wealth. But it belongs
to those who are impoverished. It
belongs to those who are in need, those
who are in a position to ask others for
aid and help and financial assistance.
And so this gives us a very interesting
view of Zak.
It gives us Zak in almost a new light
from a different angle.
And that is that when the person gives
zak,
he is actually handing over what never
belonged to him in the first place.
This is a right that Allah mentions
belongs
to those who are impoverished.
It is a right that is contained within
his wealth
that belongs to those who are in need.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions that this known and set right
belongs to those individuals who are in
need of it.
And when a person accepts Islam,
when a person stands before Allah as a
servant and a follower of Muhammad
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. He accepts
and understands that he is merely the
custodian of said wealth.
That this portion of his earnings,
though they are a result of his
earnings, they are ultimately all the
consequences of Allah's grace and mercy
and giving. and that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has allowed us the majority of
our wealth but he has set aside 2.5%
a very very small percentage
that will not harm the wealthy but will
be an immense benefit and of consequence
to those who do not have
and so it is a balance and Allah has
said to the wealthy,
"This is yours and it belongs to you. I
hereby grant you this being that you
have earned it in a hal way. But this
portion right here belongs to me. And I
have made you its custodian
and its caretaker. And that you are to
deliver it to eight types of individuals
whom I have designated be recipients of
this zaka.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has made
that a pillar of Islam.
And he has made it one of the first
things that any people will learn about
Islam.
And Bkari Muslim Abdullahb
he narrates that when the prophet Sam
sent Mu Jabal to Yemen
as his representative and a caller to
Islam and judge amongst the people of
Yemen.
He told him
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
when he sent Mu to Yemen, he said when
you arrive in Yemen,
you will encounter a people there that
are a people of the book, predominantly
Christian, but there were some pockets
of Jews there as well.
And so the first thing you are to call
them to, the first thing you are to
introduce them to of my message is
that they worship Allah alone without
any partners.
[Silence]
He said, "And if they come to accept
that,
then inform them that Allah
whom they have conceded
is to be worshiped alone without any
partners.
Inform them that Allah has obligated
upon them five daily prayers in every
day and night of theirs.
[Silence]
He said, "And if they come to accept
this and they come to practice prayer,
then inform them
that Allah has obligated upon them a
percentage of the wealth of their
wealthy, a charity that will be taken
from their wealthy and distributed back
amongst their poor.
Now notice the very critical wording
here that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam cites.
He says inform them that Allah has
obligated upon them. Who is them? The
people of Yemen. the people that he's
going to people he's been sent to by the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam inform them
that Allah has obligated upon them
a charity to be taken from their wealthy
and distributed back upon their poor.
The scholars have taken from this
narration, this wording and other
narrations
that zaka is not only to be collected
in a place but it is to be distributed
in the place in which it was collected
because zakia has many many many
benefits.
and a person receiving a check or a
person receiving some money. That is
only one of its many multiaceted
benefits.
One of the most important aspects
and angles of zaka
is that it strengthens the bonds
and closes the chasm and gaps between
the wealthy and the poor.
Throughout human history,
there has always existed a tension and a
lovehate relationship between the
wealthy and the poor.
The poor need the wealthy.
And the wealthy, they need the poor,
whether they accept that or not.
And the poor hate that they need the
wealthy. And the wealthy hate that they
need the poor. But Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has set us all up as he has said
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala has raised
some amongst us in levels above others
in order for the test that is this world
to
be adequate to judge a person's true
true person.
And so there is always a
possible
there is always a possible
vendetta or possible
discomfort.
And there is also
always this kind of
dislike that bubbles underneath the
surface between the poor and the rich.
And so one of the benefits,
one of the most critical and immense
benefits of zak is that it helps to
quell
that that dislike. It helps to quell
that when the wealthy give enough to the
poor to take care of them.
And the wealthy give enough to the poor
to make them productive in society in
their society.
And where the poor receive enough to
make them thankful to the wealthy.
And this is all part of a functioning
society.
If we have very very very wealthy people
who don't look twice at the poor, this
chasm will continue to grow between them
until it becomes combustible.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
made it that the wealthy must give the
poor and the poor must be grateful to
the wealthy
in order that they all be brothers.
And so this is a timeless
law. This is a timeless legislation of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that the
wealthy in any given place or society
are always responsible for taking care
of the poor in that society
here in America right here. If the
wealthy amongst us do not take care of
the poor and the wealthy amongst us ship
their zaka off to some other place in
the world
and then
they will say well you know hey the
government takes care of the poor here
in America so we don't really need to do
that
and so we're okay with the government
quote unquote taking care of our
brothers and sisters who are our
brothers and sisters. BUT THEN WE SHIP
OUR zak off somewhere else. How exactly
are we going to grow those bonds of
brotherhood between the wealthy and the
poor amongst us? Or is our time too
advanced and too complex for these kinds
of simple these kinds of simple
solutions?
Of course not. This is the law of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The sunnah of the
prophet Sam.
They are timeless. They are not bound by
any geographic.
These laws of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
are beneficial and we are the first to
reap the benefits of these of these laws
and these rules and regulations of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala these obligations
and so it is absolutely critical
that we take care of our poor.
Sometimes I have heard some of the most
absurd arguments
with respect to
people discussing this issue.
People that claim that there's no poor
people in America
or for instance the government will take
care of the poor or we have welfare here
in America or all these other excuses.
This money does not belong to you. This
money that is zaka in your wealth, it
never belonged to you. Never. It was
never part of that which was okay for
you to take.
It always belonged to the poor.
And it belonged to your poor brother and
sister that lives right next door. And
if he doesn't live right next door, then
two doors down and so forth.
And if he doesn't if there is
hypothetically not a single poor person
in your whole city than the next poor
person in the closest city to you. This
is how zaka works. You don't make your
own rules for this kind of money.
It is something that you are merely a
custodian of.
And it is absolutely critical for us to
go back to those original
original
obligations and really start back at the
fundamentals again and grow our roots
nice and strong again.
and that we start to give our zakat
properly to who it belongs to. And if a
person is unable to give it to who he
belongs to, then he will give it to
someone who will make sure that it
arrives in the hands of those who are
needy, those who are impoverished, those
to whom it belongs.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
right after the salah is over here in
Jum. We're asking you to stay for just
five minutes as we make a collection for
the zaka of the masjid to make sure that
we have that fund for the entirety of
the year to be able to give anyone who
is in need that comes to our doors. This
is something that is not just good for
you to do. This is your responsibility.
This is the obligation upon you by Allah
Subhanahu Waaala. This is our
responsibility.
And so we'd ask anyone that is here,
unless you have some dire emergency to
tend to, even if you are not planning to
give anything right now, at least stay
seated. remain with us because once
people start leaving then the other one
leaves and then the next one leaves and
then we're standing here talking to
ourselves. Please remain here for just
five extra minutes and allow us to make
a collection for zaka and also for the
expenditures of Ramadan. this operation
here that we all enjoy. It costs money
just anything else and we need to
make a collection for that as well
inshallah which we will explain in more
detail once the salah is over.
Allah
[Silence]
whom
All
sam.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
call it.
Allah
[Silence]
stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps.
As we mentioned, after the salah, we'll
be making a collection for zaka. We'll
be making a collection for zaka and also
for the expenditures for the month. When
you give, you will designate what of
your money that you want to or your
donation you want to be allotted to
each. Please, even if you're not giving,
the least you can give or donate is five
minutes of your time to remain seated in
order that we are able to get this done.
Shouldn't take more than about four or
five minutes and then we'll let you go
inshallah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
canister.
Amen.
for
[Silence]
Canada.
All
Allah
holy men
alone. Oh,
I
alone.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
Holy.
Amen.
Allah
[Silence]
about
me. Allah
Allah
[Silence]
Thou
alone.
Allah
bell.
[Silence]
Allah
As we mentioned, inshallah just five
minutes we will listen to our president
here a few words and then we'll start
making our collection inshallah. Just
remain seated unless you have an
emergency and I'm going to check
brothers and sisters. I just want to
explain a couple of things before we
help sheh increase you know to to
collect the funds inshallah. So the
there are two reasons why we are
collecting the funds today. First one is
zakat zakat that is obligatory to
everybody right that's 2 and a half% of
the money that we have that is does not
belong to us. it needs to be returned to
the needy people to fulfill that
request. The second part is the expenses
of the Ramadan. We do not have we we
always collect the money to take care of
those things but because of the interest
of time we decided to combine the two.
The form that we have today is pledge
forms. They have options for both of
them. So you can decide which one how
much of zakat is due to you due from
you and the second is how much you want
to donate for the masid for the Ramadan
expenses which includes the the
activities throughout the the Ramadan
and the on the day of Eid we have we
offer a breakfast and we need some money
for that also. So without any further
delay I would to ask she
[Arabic recitation]
and needs a
would to say while we do not turn
away anybody that comes in requesting
for help the pro the amount of money
that we have is proportional to how much
we can do give to those people who come
in through the door. So while we are not
turning away anybody, we just can be
more generous if you are helping us to
and that is something that key is in
your hand. You can help us make it more
generous so when people come in they are
we are able to fulfill their needs in a
better way inshallah. Right? So if the
zak fund is low, you got to come in and
go through a rigomear round, fill out an
application and get 50 bucks. Who wants
that? We want to be able to give out
some handsome checks to our needy
brothers and sisters. Make sure that
they are taken care of. Let's go ahead
and start with 10,000. Who has $10,000
that's burning a hole in his pocket?
They got to get rid of it. We have one
over here.
This is Dr.'s son.
$10,000.
Who's going to follow suit?
10,000.
We have here 10,000 as well. Dr.
So, we've got
we need we need
10,000 here. We have Dr. 10,000 here as
well. Mashallah.
10,000. Let's take a few more 10,000s. I
know that's that's, you know, that's
peanuts for some of us. Who has $10,000
that they need to get rid of before they
pass away? If you die and it's with you,
that might be a problem because that's
somebody else's money. Who has $10,000
that belongs to the poor here amongst
us? 10,000 inshallah.
10,000.
10,000. I will pledge.
[Arabic recitation]
say amen. Amen.
for the sake of time, let's move to
5,000. That is half. We should see just
a plethora of hands just shooting up all
over the place. Here we have Dr.
Mashallah.
Here
we have Dr. Usama. He's not a doctor,
but I'll call him a doctor. You could be
a doctor for a day. Over here, Ib Abu
in the green back here. Mashallah. He's
about 7 foot tall. You can't miss him
right there.
5,000. 5,000. Who else? $5,000. We
have here $5,000.
$5,000.
$5,000 of zak for thee. Here's brother
Muhammad with his shade. He has a car
that picks him up all by itself. It's
the creepiest thing you could ever see.
$5,000 inshallah. 5,000. We have
$5,000.
$5,000. And of course, this doesn't
close it off if you want to pledge it
later or do it in private, but this is
the place to do this. This is a private
thing. It's wedge for you to do it
privately so people will come out of
their shells. So, just one reminder,
this is the money you not you don't have
to pay all of it today. You can make the
payment plans. So, it's the what we are
asking for is only $400 a month, right?
[Arabic recitation]
just want you to remember this is
something that you make the pledge
inshallah Allah will make it easy for
you to deliver. So only once a month you
can pay4 $400 and that fulfills the
$5,000 pledge inshallah. We want to make
sure we never have to turn away anyone
due to a low budget ever. Ever. We never
want to turn anyone away. We want to
benefit everyone. Let's take it down to
$2,000.
$2,000
for the whole year. 25 over here.
25. Here we have brother Nadim 3,000.
[Arabic recitation]
2,000? Here we have
brother over here. 2,000. Thank you.
2,000 $2,000 for zak or for the
expenditures for Ramadan. $2,000
$2,000. We'll do $1,000.
That's for the whole year. this is
we're getting into my bracket now
of the kind of here we have Abu Ali
Mashallah 1000 over here Abu Ali. And I
know that a lot of us divide up our
zakah. Some send some home to their
country, some keep it here. So it's good
to
[Arabic recitation]
$1,000. Who else has any pledge? Now
we'll take it to five and as well here.
$500.
$500 will make this for the expenditures
for the masid. Here we have 500. 500
here in the back. Raise your hand nice
and tall. Be very proud. You know the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam tells us that
Allah despises
that a person walk boastfully in all
affairs except in the time of making a
shan cry making a shaitan weep. So
this is a time to really rub his nose in
it. $500.
We will we have 500 over here as
well. 500 raise your hand. 500 500
$500
500 for me as well. I'll do 500.
Mashallah.
500. I'm tapped out for the month. I had
to I had to 500. We have brother
Usama over here. We have 500 in the
snap snapback hat. Okay. The snap cap.
Well, it's a snapback. I I don't know
what you guys call it. These youngsters.
I used to be one young one one day five
500 anymore inshallah this is not closed
off you can come up take a slip fill it
out just make sure that you fulfill your
pledge inshallah this is your
responsibility this is your opportunity
we've this is our last for Ramadan we'll
see you next week I have a couple of
pledges that are silent pledges one is
$5,000
mashallah my shelters for that for the
the fundraising we are doing today.
There was another one silent. That's
another $1,000.
And there's another one that's unknown.
So, alhamdulillah, we have several
silent pledges. There's a four 4,000.
There's another 4,000 pledge that is
silent. So, brother and sisters, I
understand, I appreciate, and I
tremendously encourage the silent
pledges also. So just I have a couple
of quick announcements
the the 27th plan inshallah we'll have
that available tonight the the that
night between the Sunday and Monday
night that will be the 27th and we'll
spend the night here inshallah eid
prayers are going to be on at 7:30 and 9
a.m. inshallah on
the day of Eid, brother.
[Arabic recitation]
Eid is going to be at at 7:30 a.m. and
900 a.m. The first one is going to be
led by Sheh Matik. The second one is
going to be by Imam Ali.
Just a quick reminder and it's to make
it easier for everyone. If you look
around you in the front here behind me,
you see this picture here and you see
it everywhere around the masjid. It's a
scan code with your phone. You you can
scan it. It will help you pay the
donation and it also has information how
to donate via zel or any other way.
So look at look for these signs and use
them for donation. Make sure if you make
any donation in the notes field, you
write down what you want it to be spent
for so we can apply it accordingly.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
least he tells us which way he wants it.
what?
[Arabic recitation]
Thank you. I know it's a last minute.
Friday the 3rd 20 30
I know I know I know I know so so
they'll be cleaning you know we're going
to be using that day right